[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality host
of
the fine print a podcast on ramsay
networks is my co-host today
we invite your calls about your life
about your relationships your mental
health your boundaries your career your
work and your money we talk about all of
them here on the ramsay show it's a free
call and some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five colton
starts off this hour in amarillo texas
hey colton how are you
i'm doing very well dave now by himself
better than i deserve sir how can we
help
uh so i actually just moved back to the
united states from australia and uh
my girlfriend is very adamant about me
getting a credit card she says i needed
to survive in america and she's worried
that if i don't get one
in the future if we decide to get
married that it might bite us in the
butt when it comes to getting a mortgage
and all that i don't want one you
actually helped my parents get out of
credit card debt a few years ago
and i just don't know what to do about
it
i just i don't know how to approach her
about
talking about that and explaining it
without sounding like a jerk what have
the conversation's been like when you
say hey i don't want a credit card i
don't believe in in going into debt i
think there's another way what is her
reaction
um
well she's kind of
how do i put it
she doesn't i guess from my
interpretation she thinks that i don't
understand what it is because as you
know everyone in america is living off
of credit card debts and car payments
and she thinks that's a good thing
um she thinks it's a necessary thing um
we're both 22.
okay how long you been dating
about
about two years now yeah what other
things is she condescending to you about
um
let's see
i guess sometimes
i'm kind of uh when it comes to emotions
i'm a very um emotional guy when it
comes to showing love and stuff she's
not always that kind of person
um
she it's uh i i really don't know yeah
how long did you say you've been dating
again
about two years two years
wow and you've been back in the states
for two years
uh no i actually just moved back here in
the very beginning of
december i actually threaded the needle
uh getting out of australia so it was
kind of a long distance relationship up
until the last few months
um so we actually met as missionaries
overseas i can't say exactly where but
and then we start dating about a year
after departing so
okay this this is going to be a
conversation where you need to maybe
show her some information not to prove
her wrong but just to show her that
there is another way and so one of the
easiest ways to do that we did an
episode on the fine print about this
very topic called the dirty truth behind
your credit score we also did one on
credit card rewards so depending on what
angle sounds like she's saying well you
need debt to survive and if you need
debt you need a high credit score and
therefore you need to use the credit
card and so in a logical sense we can
show her that you don't need those
things and i've gotten a mortgage
without a credit score and so it can be
done but she's going to need to get some
new information in order to maybe see
that what were you guys missionaries for
bank of america
uh
no actually christian missionaries with
a useless mission yeah youth with a
mission christian missionaries show
bible believing
okay yes sir so let me help you with
this then let's let's maybe uh have this
discussion through a different lens
okay okay
i would uh challenge either one of you
as i have people for decades you
wouldn't be the first to to find me one
time in scripture that god used debt to
deliver his people or bless his people
show me one positive reference to that
in scripture
by the way i'll help you with this
here's a hack it's not there
it's not a sin
listed in scripture but 100 percent of
the time that that debt is mentioned in
the bible is a negative reference
you're a fool you're a slave
you're impulsive
these are the things that come around
the word debt as you read through and
study the scriptures and there's
hundreds and hundreds of references
to that in the scripture and they're all
negative
so if we're going to look at this
through
the lens of the bible which your founder
lauren cunningham would tell you to have
done at youth with a mission very
familiar with your ministry
and uh and an admirer of the ministry by
the way but um
but the uh uh
uh
you know if you look at this through the
lens of scripture there's nothing in
there that says that debt is the way to
win as a matter of fact it says it's the
way to lose now it's it's not a
salvation issue and it's not a sin
it's just biblically speaking stupid
that's what it amounts to and so maybe
that's a way to have the discussion uh
and then you can also go at it with uh
secular or mainstream information like
george is talking about because here's
the thing
you're 22 years old
okay she's 22 years old she does not
have all the answers to the money
equation i can assure you of this sir
as a matter of fact she has almost none
of the answers and she's pretty
condescending about the fact that she
knows nothing
so here's the thing you can get a
mortgage
without a credit score
it's called manual underwriting
if you want to buy a car you should pay
cash if you want to become wealthy and
build wealth
yes sir that's uh that's actually one of
the
arguments that i have and i haven't made
it yet because uh she's paying off a
vehicle yeah and i which was stupid
no i've been stupid too i've had car
payments i've had lots of payments i was
did a lot of stupid stuff that's what
qualifies me to teach this is i've
looked i got stupid a bunch of it in the
rear view mirror
and so um i mean i i made an art form
for a while so i you know
her little car payment is not nearly as
stupid as i've been but
uh and then lastly is this that you know
the thing
as a
a father of
grown children which is an oxymoron as a
father of grown-ups
um
uh the thing that concerns me about the
most about this conversation is how
condescending she is towards you
from a relationship standpoint as if
you're a doofus and she has it all
figured out which from my seat is kind
of funny
laughable except they accept how it
plays out in your relationship so i
think that that needs to be addressed in
your relationship going forward that you
guys can have a conversation where you
have equal footing intellectually
spiritually to have a a calm good mature
discussion about something instead of
her going well you just don't know
little man well you're freaking 22 lady
i mean seriously i got socks older than
you
so this is ingrained in their in their
brains
you know but if it's a values thing it
may not work out long term yeah money
fights money problems number one cause
of divorce so either you guys get on the
same page or this may not be the right
fit
forever
sorry
yeah
that's a possibility too
i may be your signal
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
did
[Music]
[Music]
well guys we are so excited smart
conference is back this fall
october 22nd we're bringing this
world-class event to dallas
texas there'll be thousands of you there
you'll spend the whole day getting the
tools and inspiration you need to be
smart you go home believing you can meet
your goals you can build wealth you can
grow as a leader you can have mental
health and wellness you can deal with
your relationship struggles you can get
the job of your dreams yes you can and
you can have the marriage of your dreams
too rachel cruz dr john deloney ken
coleman george campbell christina ellis
pedro la torre and special guest craig
and amy groschell good friends of ours
pastor of the largest church in america
today lifechurch.tv over in oklahoma
city they'll be speaking on marriage so
it is quite a day
you're going to leave smarter in every
area of your life
you know there's so much trash filth and
nastiness going into people's brains out
there george crap is everywhere going
and if you put crap in your brain all
day your brain will be crap you need to
put something smart in your brain
all day long on october 22nd in dallas
this is gonna be fun it's it's like
drinking from the fire hose if you've
ever wanted a taste of what we do here
at ramsey solutions this is the event
for you we're going eight to five
non-stop we cover all the areas of life
that are looming in your brain that give
you that anxiety from money to
relationships to career and powerhouse
speakers of course with all of our
ramsey personalities being there and
i've got to host this event for many
many years and it truly is my favorite
event that we do and now you'll be one
of the keynotes and i get to speak for
the very first time so that's one reason
to go not a great one but it's one no
it's it's a great reason it's a great
we're gonna have a great time it'll be
an incredible talk i've seen the outline
and a texas crowd i mean there's nothing
like a game on baby i am ready for this
yeah
i'm so excited get to be with human
beings and everything yes man this is a
destination event october 22nd listen
the ticket prices went on sale the
tickets went on sale today
so the prices are at early bird specials
that means uh oh wait a minute they're
going to be gone real soon like by the
time i finish talking about this
probably but uh you better get on there
and get it ramseysolutions.com
events get your tickets october 22nd
we're gonna be in dallas you're gonna be
smarter if you come it's a smart
conference that's true no one leaves
dumber i can tell you that much i can
tell you that i can tell you that so
george i think we need to go back for a
second
because i had um with our our last
caller
two two youngsters okay but
y'all kind of felt me rise up about that
i felt it yeah yeah and it wasn't
caffeine
here's the thing 30 years of doing this
and people
being condescending
to other people who want to live a
debt-free life and build wealth the
shortest fastest possible way
the way that actually works instead
these other people are stealing their
hope
and regardless of your age
that condes that that that condescending
attitude that i'm gonna look down my
nose and go oh you just don't understand
you you poor little people you just
don't understand
and
there's something about hope stealers
regardless of whether you're a sweet
little 22 year old girl or whether
you're a crusty old
61 year old jerk like me
if you're a hope stealer
i'm gonna rise up on you that's what i'm
rising up on
because that just that ticks me off yeah
keeps people from
le you know and it's such a passive
aggressive form of persuasion
that and it keeps people from living a
wonderful life
and and
you know and the problem is
that that not only are they arrogant and
condescending these people that do these
kinds of things but they um
they're wrong that is true well it comes
down to is they have a fixed mindset and
their brain says what i know to be true
will always be true and i don't have a
different picture of what this life
looks like and because of my upbringing
in my experience what i know from
culture this is just how it has to go
and we're out here preaching every day
to people saying there's a different way
over here look there's hope you don't
have to stay in debt forever you can
build wealth the little man can get
ahead and so that's what we do every
single day is trying to help people get
that growth mindset to give them that
hope give them actions they can take to
change their life and those people just
don't believe that they can change but
you're just you know you're just such
you and rachel are just so much nicer
about it than i well yeah i don't maybe
it'll come with age or maybe
30 years would just get disgusted and i
just because i just it's just
because i can see this great young man
who's been out there serving god with
youth with a mission coming home and
having a wonderful life but yeah you
don't understand
you don't know how life works you poor
little thing which she just came off the
mission field too yeah i mean it's not
like like she's been here learning
something
but what happens is the credit card
becomes a gateway drug to all kinds of
other types of debt and you go well if
i'm okay with payments over here what's
wrong with a car payment and what's
wrong with having debt over here in a
personal loan and the mortgage and so
this starts to crush your financial life
and then you get upset because you don't
have any money at the end of the month
see when when you say gateway drug in
your nice voice it sounds so so pleasant
when i say it it sounds like i just i
just cut somebody's head off it's a
gateway drug you know you're like is
listen i'm like dare okay that's me i'm
trying to help the youth of just a nice
guy stay off of drugs that's a stat
don't do drugs dare
and we're gonna start a dare program we
ingrain that into society but when it
comes to debt we're not doing a great
job because it's the parents telling
them to say no just saying no that was
nancy reagan's thing right just saying
that just say no to credit cards just
say no to credit cards there you go
that's the new campaign
you can take that one for free you know
what it's old enough we could restart it
with the 22 year olds because they've
never heard of it
it's vintage to them it's amazing it's
like retro maybe i'm older than i
thought oh too fun oh good stuff
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
pamela's with us in north carolina hi
pamela welcome to the ramsey show
hello sir how are you doing today
better than i deserve what's up
i'm glad to hear that um yes um so what
is going on with me um i'm on baby step
two
and i have a beat a car and i've been
using that to
to work on my side hustle so i can you
know um snowball some
some money and pay off my dad
um
just a couple days ago when i was on my
side hustle um my car cut off i couldn't
cut it back on
so um i got it towed and i just received
news from the mechanic
that um the head gasket is blown
and there's gonna be thousands of
dollars to repair which um i do not have
and i was just wondering if maybe
um you guys had a solution
man i'm sorry that just rips your that
just makes your stomach hurt
oh yeah i've been there and this stupid
car breaks at exactly the wrong time
like it's a country song i mean it's
ridiculous you know oh my gosh yes sir
that's unfortunate pamela so have you
got a quote from anyone else is this a
normal price people pay for head gaskets
that's thousands yeah it's gone well it
sounds like it's worth more than the car
is
what is the car worth um
um
i looked on
kelly blue book
about a week or so ago
and i believe that the um
it's between like like i think like
thirty four hundred and like five
thousand fair market value
is around four
and um
it shouldn't cost thousands to do a head
gasket but it might cost a thousand
well that that's that's what um
that's what uh the mechanic was saying
because i because i was anticipating
thousands and she's and um she mentioned
that yeah it'll it'll
they were talking about the labor and
the labor was already it was already at
two
million
dollars yes
labor to do a head job on a four
thousand dollar car i don't think so yes
i don't think so where did you take this
the dealer
um no sir um it's it's like i said it's
a beater so um i i took it to my
mechanic i took it to triple a yeah
i hope that was okay to say uncle
on live on live radio
it's fine that's fine they're not
mechanics they're just your insurance
plan um
okay i can't leave you on the side of
the road going into a break with 15
seconds so we're going to take you up
when we come right back and answer your
questions so hang on through this break
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today pamela in wilmington north
carolina is on the line we're talking
with her going into the break sure the
head blew on her car she's gotta have a
head gasket put on they're quoting her
two thousand dollars labor alone on a
three four thousand dollar car
um and so she's stuck you were using the
car you said for your side hustle how
are you getting to work on your regular
job
well i um i have a a roommate and um she
dropped me off the past couple days okay
and so that's your short-term plan you
have any money saved at all
um well like i said i was on i'm on baby
step two i did have the a thousand
dollars saved
um but we had a um
we we had a a we had a another roommate
and a huge water bill in the often and
they were talking like cutting it off
um on monday
so i i took a portion of my um of that
of that emergency fund it paid for the
water bill so we would still have water
i'm sorry
okay so what are you making what do you
make
what's your income
i make a little less than um than 32 000
a year okay
all right
um so what we've got you're going to
have to fix this with an uncomfortable
short-term solution because you don't
have a lot of options
and then you're going to work towards a
better long-term solution
so right it sounds like okay
number one i'd like to get another
opinion on this car from somebody if you
can get someone else to give you a
second opinion on a different price
this price sounds okay it sounds high to
me
okay and it depends what kind of car is
it
it's a 2000 lexus
okay
that it just it feels high
okay uh for 2 000 labor alone for a head
job i could be wrong but that feels high
and you don't have it so it doesn't
matter but if you if you could get a if
you can get a price that you could
scratch up while you ride with your
roommate to work and fix it that'd be
great that's rule that's thing one thing
two is if that doesn't work you're gonna
sell the car as is for a couple grand
probably is all you're gonna get for it
and you're gonna take that two thousand
dollars and whatever other money you can
scratch together and buy you a garage
sale car
to get around in right now that's your
short term solution and then as fast as
possible run the side hustle as fast as
possible run as many hours as you can
and move up out of that up into a three
or four thousand dollar car all with
cash please do not let this force you
into a long-term problem which is called
a car payment
and a lot of people in your situation
jump from the fire into the frying pan
and um
or from the frying pan into the fire
whichever way we want to run that
metaphor but um
you know and that's what i don't want
you to do here so get a second opinion
if you if that confirms the pricing on
the la on the repair and i'm wrong which
i might be uh then sell the car and buy
a car for cash with whatever cash you
can get in your hand
and that's going to be a what we call a
garage sale car it's a car it's a it's
not a
it's a car that's not much of a car it's
worse than the one you're driving except
that it's hard to imagine except that it
runs and we're pausing the dead snowball
while we turn this up pop pause
everything until you can get yourself
back into a decent car
by decent i mean a four or five thousand
dollar car here move up back up in car
you you're in a situation where you
cannot afford to have this kind of thing
happen
and so you don't have any wiggle room
any margin
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage carl and robin are with
us hey guys how are you hey great dave
welcome where do you guys live uh
half hour north of detroit in northville
michigan got it well welcome to
nashville good to have you here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off uh well yeah we started financial
peace university class in
2015
and we had 399 000 in debt whoa
but in reality we read your book in 2009
after the 2008 real estate crash
and um you know we had a bunch of debt
from
rental properties and
and such and it was about 685 thousand
dollars that's where i'd worked down to
by what year did you say you went
through fpu then uh 2015 15. yeah okay
and so you got seven years to pay off
400 grand right right okay all right
cool what was your range of income
during that time uh between 170 to 230.
wow what do you guys do for a living
we're both engineers at ford oh very
good transmissions very good good for
you the blue oval there you go i love it
i love it sounds like you've been there
a while yep all right yep very good so
you paid off all the rental debt and
then when you went through financial
peace university you decided to attack
the rest of this what kind of debt was
the 400
um well it was the rental debt actually
we didn't pay it off but we you know we
did the davish plan i guess until then
until then yeah so uh we weren't making
enough progress and um we uh we we were
looking for something else so then we
take the class and we uh we really you
know got gazelle intense sold everything
bought a bought a 1997 buick riviera wow
as our dave carr you bought the enemy's
car right yes you bought a general
motors car and you're working forward
yes yes but if you're going to drive a
junk or drive the enemies right
it was comfortable and it was fast
i love it good
okay so then you work your way through
this now is this your home and
everything now yes sir you're out so
we're looking at weird people you're 100
debt free yep 100 debt free yes i love
it that is so very cool so what's this
house worth
uh it's probably worth about 500 yeah i
think do you own some of the rental
properties still uh we sold uh
three or two of them and we still have
one of them that's paid for that's paid
what's it worth yeah about 150 okay yeah
so you're probably also baby steps
millionaires simultaneously then
yeah we are yeah
yeah that's amazing thank you yeah
yeah all right that's incredible i mean
they got 700 000 in real estate so you
know you know they're you know they're
uh and they're engineers so i imagine
401k number one number one uh career
field of millionaires yes awesome guys
the engineers this is incredible so what
kind of sacrifices were you guys making
because you said you were dave ish and
then you went gazelle intense what did
that change look like
um
well we we just uh you know scratched
and clawed and we we um
you know we ate at home a lot and uh you
know these boys really kicked in and
helped with rental repairs and
car repairs and uh you know maintaining
our home for us you know
you know with the help of us and um
you know they didn't they didn't want
the best of the best they didn't want
the best shoes or that you know even
though we you know northville's kind of
a ritzy area you know in michigan there
and
and they um they really uh they live
like no one else yeah yeah so they can
live like no one else how does it feel
to be completely
debt-free it's wonderful
yeah
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
um
it it's it's kind of when you're going
along with the plan you might feel like
you've made mistakes or you might want
to give up or and i just tell people to
give yourself grace no one's perfect
um still keep your eye on the plan and
you can do it like have some faith in
yourself and
and you know everybody makes mistakes
and just just keep going just just keep
doing it it's it's she's like a great
mom i can tell you can tell she's a
great mom i love it the boys are all
agreeing
you guys are awesome this is very cool
way to go you guys way to go so very
awesome good stuff all right so uh
man i'm telling you this is amazing so
you went to financial peace university
at your church yep and uh we want to
thank steve cooper for uh for running it
for us and um yeah it was at saint edith
catholic church in livonia michigan yeah
very yeah he's a very good teacher very
good good stuff well it makes a
difference it makes a big difference to
be plugged in with other people while
you're doing starting and doing the
journey too for that matter oh yeah very
good way to go guys we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires to celebrate the
fact that you are one yeah you'll read
about people in there just like you yeah
i like it well done very good and a copy
of total money makeover for you to give
away to someone and get them moving and
get them on their journey all right
congratulations we're very proud of you
all right and the boys names are
uh calvin reed and albert all right here
we go carl robin calvin reed and albert
from the detroit michigan area 400 000
paid off in seven years house and
everything making 170 to 230. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two
[Music]
i one it
yeah baby that's how it's done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us america george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money julia is with us in
portland maine hi julia welcome to the
ramsey show
thank you so much it's an honor to speak
with you both today you too what's up
so i am on baby step six and i have a
rental property
do you recommend that i include 15 of my
rental income
in my retirement contribution no
okay good because i want to throw
everything at my mortgage yeah not
everything
you you have other income don't you
yes yes i have a regular job so what is
your regular job pay what does it pay uh
so i'm a freelancer and i make about 115
000 a year nice so julia the point is
not the magic of
15 works but if you do 14 you're going
to be poor i mean it's not it's not that
precise the idea is to put a large
chunk which 15 is but not so large
that you can't get your out other debts
paid off on your house
and that's where the 15 came from
because when i first started this i
would have people doing they're putting
25 away
or they're putting one percent or
they're putting one percent away and so
what i ended up doing was we were you
know we got with the financial coaches
that here on our staff and we ran a
bunch of scenarios and said okay what if
you were this income and you say 15
would you be okay and this age and what
what if you if you saved 12 percent and
if you save 17 and if you save 10 or 20
and we kind of went back and forth and
so what we've zoned in on is that most
any age at most any income 15 percent's
a good healthy amount
but it's not a magical it's not a magic
number
so you know you see what i'm saying so
i'm going to stick with it i'm going to
tell you to do 15 because it's worked
and it's a proven plan that lots and
lots of people have done yeah and julia
once you do pay off that mortgage and
you're in baby step seven you could
increase that oh you're going there
yeah you max out everything but right
now we've got to get our priorities
and paying off the house is a1 yeah
that's a great question yeah that that's
very good but the point on these
guidelines for these process people is
is a it's proven
millions of people have done this and it
worked and she wasn't trying to change
it she just getting clarification
b
um some of these things are just based
on
some common sense principles and this
idea of baby step four being 15 baby
step four is put a good healthy amount
on your retirement
but not so much that you can't find some
spillover to put on your house and get
your house paid off but not so little
that you end up with nothing in your
retirement in a paid for house you have
to dig the bushes up and eat them oh
yeah because you've got no money and
saving for kids college you know exactly
you want to be able to
leave some money to spill over in the
budget to five and six because five and
six are baby steps five and six are
simultaneous with baby step four and
that's where the number comes from and
then it ran it's a bunch of case studies
and a bunch of possible scenarios that
we ran out and here's what's weird
you take somebody make it twenty
thousand dollars a year
they say fifteen percent and they never
get a raise they're still they're not
gonna be rich but but they never really
made any money they've been at the
poverty level yeah and they still end up
with a really nice mistake it's not
about the amount of money it's how much
time that has to grow
a little bit amount over a long period
of time it's amazing what can happen
with compound growth yeah and and of
course we all know that where you are
today is not your destiny that life is a
film strip it's not a snapshot
and so you're you're going to get better
get worse and in a lot of areas your
health your relationships your money
your income your career and and so it's
not a static you never have a static
situation either but we ran the
scenarios on static just because it was
the easiest set of variables you never
got an extra dime in your income are you
still okay yes you're still okay all
right jennifer is with us in raleigh hi
jennifer how are you
i'm doing fine thanks and how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so
question is about whether we have too
much life insurance um
we're in a unique situation in that we
can't add life insurance once we drop it
my husband is uninsurable
and so if what we have for life
insurance was carried over from a
previous employer and we just carried on
paying it but we're kind of wondering if
now if it's more than what we really
need and we could use those
you know that money in a different place
wow
why is he uninsurable
he had a heart transplant
oh that'll do it
yep yeah and we we checked and they
confirmed yeah you know yeah that's
that's a tough one there yeah so how's
he doing
he's doing fantastic how long ago was he
always
uh we're coming up on four years ago
awesome how old is he
he is 50 years old that's amazing that's
so powerful
well praise god that's awesome good it
was an amazing um long journey but we
made it through and he's doing
fantastic we should not complain that's
just wow
okay so uh why do you have
too much life insurance what do you mean
by that
well i just mean that it's it's very
expensive so
it's carried over from an old employer
so when we left we had to have we had
the opportunity to keep it
and we knew even back then which has
been
oh gosh that was like 2007. um we knew
it would be expensive but we also knew
we couldn't get it and he generally
throughout his career has not worked for
large companies so
we've kept it as our only option so how
much is it how much is the coverage and
how much is the premium
it's 480 000 in coverage and right now
because we just hit 50 we're paying 720
dollars a quarter
quarter okay okay all right twenty eight
hundred dollars a year
twenty nine hundred dollars here
fifty years old okay what's his income
his income 150. what's the rest of your
financial situation
um i also work so
um i make 75 so between the two of us
we're 225
we have a mortgage that is our only debt
um our kids are grown and through
college and on their own and off my
payroll which is fantastic
yeah huge ding ding um
we save 15 in our retirement uh how much
is in there
uh
somewhere between 1.2 and 1.8 billion
so the question you ask yourself is this
and you answer it with math by the way
not a feeling
if he died
and you didn't have any life insurance
on him and you had a million two no kids
at home and a house with a mortgage and
you make seventy five thousand dollars a
year are you okay
and i think the answer is yes
how old are you
50.
okay that's all okay
none of this million too you can access
to your 59 and a half right
correct but if he died it'd be an
inherited ira uh portions of it and you
could access it
that's the scenario we're running out
not predicting which is it's because
we're asking about life insurance which
is actually death insurance right so
um so uh
you know can you make it on
a hundred thousand dollars a year in
addition to your income
and still get your mortgage paid off and
still have a good life i suspect you can
by the way
okay
all right and there's one other thing it
just dawned on me i also
have insurance on him through my
employer
you know the max still allowed me to do
without any kind of medical
review so i think between that
that yeah we
we i would be okay right yeah well
that's that's what you need to run out
and and if the answer is yes i'm okay
you know i'm a millionaire
with a paid for house or are close to
paid for house i'm sorry and the kids
are grown and gone am i okay if he
leaves me no life insurance then that's
when you are self-insured
and you don't need it
you know now if you want it you want to
keep it you make enough money to pay 3
000 a year and keep this around for a
few more years until you feel really
good about that decision because you're
right once you drop it you're not
getting any more yeah and to dave's
point it's not about how you feel about
it run the budget see what your
household expenses are could you make it
by peeling off a percentage of what's in
that inherited ira and i think the
answer is yes based on your current
income and expenses and lifestyle and so
that's what we end up doing to call it
self-insured and it gives you some peace
and that's why we teach you to do these
baby steps and once the life insurance
is out after 15-20 years you don't need
it anymore if you follow our plan yeah
and
you know just be real sure that you're
really comfortable because you don't get
a second shot at this yeah in your
situation
so it's a good question it's a it's an
absolute yes or no though you have to
make a decision permanently
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print
podcast where you can learn what happens
in the fine print on the ramsey networks
he's my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five as we talk about your money your
relationships your boundaries your
mental health even yes we dare to go
there and of course your work and your
careers it's all about you and your life
it's called the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five
martin is with us in albuquerque new
mexico hey martin welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
i um i have a charge off loan uh that
was charged off i believe in
uh august 27th or not i'm sorry i'm
sorry
uh it was charged off uh actually not
too long ago it's a loan for eight
thousand dollars and i have a back story
with it but i just want to know what are
the steps to
um
tackling this loan considering it's only
been about
six to eight months that i have not paid
what kind of loan
well it's just a personal loan at the
time uh before i was interested in
investing and saving i
got a loan when i had a job to purchase
a
dream car i wanted
okay so you're eight thousand dollars to
who
uh it's a it's an online lender called
lightstream okay
all right i'm with you now all right
george so
why weren't you able to pay the loan
uh i got injured back in january 22nd of
last year i was a ups driver i fell out
of the back of a truck
and hit my back
my work did not work with me and so i
eventually got a lawyer to fight against
eps
we finally settled after a year i just
got the settlement check about a week
ago and i'm holding on to it for certain
reasons and this is one of them okay how
much is the check
uh we sold for 15 600.
all right and have you worked at all
since
uh no sir i've i've been
injured stuck at home okay so have you
had any income any disability anything
like that
uh no sir what are you gonna do for your
career going forward
um
right now i'm going back to school i'm
going for my
my associates for business
and hopefully going farther than that as
soon as i'm done with that i have about
five classes left for that
are you living with your parents
yes sir yes sir my i'm living with my
mother she's she's been taking care of
me uh since then god bless her wow
how are you paying for the school
uh she
offered to pay for one class for it
right now
i registered for two and luckily my
school gave me a 500
grant
so the bill
came out to a hundred dollars
good okay very good
do you have any other debt uh
yes sir yes sir i um just before this
call i spoke to nusenda my banking and i
have two credit cards that are
maxed out
um because i was paying for stuff after
i was injured
um so those are maxed out at 2500
each your total
total for both credit cards one's a
thousand dollars and one's fifteen
hundred okay
they they i tried working with them my
mom tried working with them uh seeing if
they could lower it if she was willing
to pay it off
um unfortunately the only thing they can
do is lower the interest rate and the
minimum payment
are you current with them
yes sir okay and that's why yeah
all right and that's all the debt
yes sir yes okay are you up and around
where you're able to do something to
create an income while you're in school
right now after a year my back is
starting to
get
better i've noticed some improvements
i still want to go
with the doctors because in my
settlement i was i received a twenty
thousand dollar
uh medical
um
i guess just for medical i'm not
suggesting that you don't finish your
medical care i'm suggesting you go
create an income
are you able to do that
i believe so yes yeah you're up walking
around right
yes sir okay then you can go do
something you're not gonna load trucks
again
you're not gonna be in a position to do
that you've got a back injury i didn't i
didn't suggest that i don't want you go
lifting heavy trays as a waiter you're
not gonna be able to do that right now
okay you may someday but right now you
can't but you could go do something that
did not require physical labor and
there's lots of those things available
right now
yes sir and you need to create some
income
it'll be good for your attitude and your
pocketbook
and with the settlement check i mean we
can clean up this debt today was there
anything else you wanted to do with it
other than i want you to cash flow the
rest of your school for sure
yes sir i uh i was just
my mother and i had a plan um
she wanted to try to settle the debts
and try to lower them
um
considering
after we if we were to pay everything
off without trying to lower it it would
only come out to
around
five grand maybe a little bit less than
that so
um and i'm not sure how much interest
rate or fees or anything
here's what i would do i'd write a check
today and pay off your credit cards and
get some scissors out and cut them up
okay where you never use them again okay
the second thing i do is i'd call this
company that you've got the eight
thousand dollars with and you haven't
paid since august and ask them what they
will take as settlement in full
okay
and they will probably take five grand
or four grand or something they're
probably going to make you an offer
and if they make you an offer that's
less than eight thousand dollars take it
and write them a check
get it in writing from them
before you send them money that they're
agreeing to accept x number of dollars
as settlement in full that's the
phrase you're looking for settlement in
full
okay okay uh is there a difference
between uh pay and delete
pay and delete
yes yes sir uh for it's a chart i i just
looked a bunch of youtube videos and
i saw that pay and delete doesn't mean
anything that's that's not even that
doesn't even exist
yes sir okay they
pay and delete means if you pay the loan
off they're going to delete the loan
duh
okay of course they're gonna do that but
no you need the the legal phrase is
settlement in full you are making a
settlement and they're accepting it as
payment in full
yes sir so settlement in full and you
need that in an email or something in
writing and you keep a hard copy of it
with a copy of the check that you wrote
or the wire transfer that you did or
whatever it was in a file for the rest
of your life
because this may come up against it it
may come up again it may come back and
bite you later and you'll have to have
proof that you settled this and got rid
of it yeah i wouldn't spend too much
more time and energy trying to fight all
this stuff you took out the debt pay it
off and move on with your life man you
got a bright life ahead of you bright
future and that's what we want for you
if you've got no debt hanging over you
and you've still got a little money in
your pocket which would be the case here
and you're in school and you're starting
to create an income now your future is
brightening back up again that's what
i'm trying to put together a total life
picture here for where you're going but
you need to go create some income
starting this week sir
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
well many of you been filing your taxes
with the same software for years but
you're actually sick of that software
you're tired of the add-on fees you're
tired of the ads telling you it's free
to do your taxes but then it's not free
and you're tired of the free criteria
not being met you're tired of them
trying to sell you debt while you're
trying to you were just trying to do
your taxes
we think you deserve better that's why
we're offering ramsey smart tax so you
can file your taxes online
without paying more than you'd expect
ramsey smart tax includes every form you
need no hidden fees
no surprises
no ads we even have a promo code right
now so you can file your federal taxes
for free and if you'd prefer to have a
priority have priority support and
extended audit protection you can go
with our premium version
it's a whole twenty dollars
if you're ready to ditch the other guys
surprising fees and save on your taxes
go to ramseysolutions.com
smart tax get started right now ramsay
solutions dot com slash
smart tax joe is with us joe's in
chicago hi joe how are you
i'm good dave thanks for taking my call
how are you doing better than i deserve
what's up
uh so question is uh currently i am in
baby step two
um i've got
seventeen thousand dollars in student
loans left um that's the only debt that
i have
i live in chicago with my girlfriend um
i make
sixty thousand a year um
i just bump that up i have two jobs now
both are work from home
uh the main one is 40 secondary one is
20. um
and my question is so
i've been in chicago pretty much my
whole life
my girlfriend's been here for about 10
years or so and i'm pretty much fed up
with living here um
and i want to get out and i want to move
and she's very much on board
the only thing obviously holding me back
is
the student loan debt and
what i have right now is about ten
thousand dollars in cash um and i know
moving can be pretty expensive we don't
really have you know
that many things uh we rent an apartment
right now
so i guess you know my question is
would it be smart to move now
um out of here because just mentally and
emotionally it's just not really good
for me um
or just hunker down for another two
years seems kind of unbearable at the
moment well two years would be
ridiculous to pay off 17 grand
right it shouldn't take you two years
you'll do it in a year
but i think you ought to go ahead and
move probably i mean what are you gonna
do your job you're gonna get a job
before you move where are you moving
i mean uh the good thing about both jobs
is that they're both uh working home so
i can i can work from anywhere so when
you say you're fed up i mean if you're
at home all day working where is it
where is this coming from when you say
it's taking a toll on your mental health
well i mean i even though i do work from
home like you know i'm still out in the
city and you know just politically
socially with
crime and
and everything else and i'm
talking about moving to
uh out west uh either to montana or um
oregon or colorado montana being number
one on the list would your cost of
living go down depending on where you go
out there
yeah it would depend i've got it
narrowed down to a few cities um it
would be
similar it'd be a little bit more
expensive we've got a pretty sweet deal
on our rents right now um
but it wouldn't be that much of a jump
okay it should be a drop
yeah depending on the city almost
anywhere in montana is cheaper than
chicago
yeah
that's kind of a
yeah i mean if you move into portland
oregon maybe not but if you move into
any of the rest of oregon you should be
cheaper than chicago yeah i mean i'd go
ahead and move and then whatever money's
left we're throwing that at the debt
except for your thousand dollar starter
emergency fund and we're getting rid of
this thing i would think you would drop
your cost of living if you're smart
about how you do this
and that would accelerate you getting
out of debt more than the cost of the
move does
and so i'm gonna load up the truck and
head to beverly baby let's move it's
time beverly montana is where he's going
apparently there we go
have a good move joe
peyton is in houston hey peyton what's
up
peyton
hi dave can you hear me barely what's up
uh i had a question for you so uh i've
been a long time listener and
i'm actually just now kind of restarting
on my baby steps
i am
77 000 in debt and that is
around 20 and
20 in credit cards 17 000 in student
loans and the rest is on a truck i use
the truck for work
so my position with work i have a uh
a base pay of 600 a week
i get a 500 bonus each month
and uh the rest is commissioned
and i'm looking to take home
commission around eight anywhere from
eight to ten thousand
a month
now i am a 1099 employee as well so
thinking taking that into account
but my question is how do i need to go
about uh
with a budget knowing that uh
knowing that i am partially commissioned
so you're talking about a regular income
how do i budget for that
right so uh
it's pretty i got it all you continue
i've got it all lined out
right now i am looking about 3 500
a month
is what
should be going out
and that includes you know all bills all
debt
and you know just living expensive
groceries and whatnot uh
that sounds like more than you're taking
home doesn't it
no well that's more than my uh
guaranteed salary again eight thousand a
month coming in
8 000 to 10 000 just in my commission
just in commissions okay well with a
regular income you've got a baseline
don't you what's the lowest amount that
you probably would make in a given month
the absolute lowest would be 2 400. okay
but that's pretty right 600
you're always going to get some
commission what's a horrible month look
like with commission um
a horrible month with probably
i would say 3 000
on top of the 2400
correct yeah so your baseline let's call
it 5500 bucks so at that point i'm gonna
list out the most important thing that
needs to get paid you know that's gonna
be your four walls your food utilities
shelter transportation so make a list of
all the priorities in that budget and as
you get more money the next thing gets
paid and the next thing gets paid so
that might mean you don't have fund
money for the month because that's
probably at the bottom of the list but
you kept the lights on and so that's how
we talk about budgeting for regular
income and dave can add some some flavor
in here but that's how i would do it
because we know a baseline yeah i would
run a regular budget on five grand a
month
because you just about a hundred percent
of the time we're gonna get that
and then snowball the rest and then and
then no not snowball the road you could
throw the rest at the snowball if you
want but then prioritize the rest
and say okay whatever didn't make the
cut that you'd like to do or want to do
or should do with money that didn't make
the cut for the five grand budget
then you make a list of those things you
go okay if i make five thousand and one
dollar what's that one dollar what's the
most important thing on this list that
didn't make it in the regular budget you
see what i'm saying
and then you prioritize that list and so
if you make
you know and you can go right down that
list as far as the money goes above five
thousand so one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten oh we got through
number 12
on the list with the extra 5 000 bucks
we made this month because we had a 10
000 total month or whatever however it
works out but run your budget out on a
regular budget on 5 000
and then
uh because you are 100
sure you're gonna get that i mean that
that's like the worst case scenario
and then
you know make a prioritized list of
anything that didn't make the cut in
that five thousand dollar budget and
work it down when the money comes in
work it down work it down work it down
work it down from there
so a really good question peyton by the
way you can pick up the every dollar app
and it'll help you do that when you're
budgeting every dollar you can jump in
and make the changes as you go through
the month and it helps you to facilitate
that one of the things our guys are
working on our programming up there's to
build out the whole irregular income
thing for every dollar but you can use
every dollar by just going and making
the changes and it's very easy to do and
still track your money you don't get a
pass because you have a regular income
you still got to do the budget you still
got to have a plan and plan out further
than the money can possibly come every
month
and that way you always have every
dollar still always has a name
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of
[Music]
firsts as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost-sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage andrew and
tiffany are with us hey guys how are you
good how you doing great dave welcome
where do you guys live lafayette
louisiana oh fun welcome to nashville
good to have you guys so good to have
you all right how much debt are you paid
off
81 928
good how long did that take you about 21
months good
and your range of income during that
almost two years
it was 90 to 150 000 good for you guys
what do y'all do for a living
we're both registered nurses i'm a
regional manager for vascular access
company
and i'm a nurse educator at a technical
college oh very good very good good good
careers well done what kind of debt was
this 82 000
it was a bunch of everything some
eight student loans
seven credit cards
a personal loan car loan and some
medical bills partridge in a pear tree
pretty boring well you guys were kind of
normal yeah normal sucks it does
how long you been married
two and a half years oh okay
so not long after that uh you look up
and say uh normal sucks we want to get
out of this
how did this all happen tell us your
ramsey story
well we had got pregnant with our second
son
and i finally did a budget
and i realized that we couldn't afford
to have another son we couldn't afford
to feed another baby because
all of our money was going to payments
we both each had four two jobs apiece so
four jobs as nurses making great money
but everything went to a payment
and i sat down and i did a rough draft
of a budget and i just cried and cried
because i couldn't afford daycare i
couldn't afford diapers we couldn't
afford anything
um
additional to what we already had
and so i had started talking to
him about um financial peace my sister
had actually gifted it to me as a
christmas present and it was in a closet
somewhere of course
and i dug it out and we started watching
the videos and getting psyched up and we
made that first budget together
as a couple and we both just looked at
it saying oh my god
we've got to change something we've got
to do something different we can do this
that's incredible so you went from
sadness to fear to anger to excitement
about finding a way out yes
wow
incredible
[Laughter]
yeah that budget is a wake-up call it's
like ah
and then you get and then you start to
go wait a minute but we we can do that
and we can do that it automatically
leads you towards solutions doesn't it
right right and we noticed we started
working together more communicating more
and we just got on that same page and we
just tackled it with a vengeance yeah
way to go you guys all right you did it
you are officially successful you're not
a theory
you actually did it you paid off 82 000
in debt
very impressive in 21 months
now people are listening maybe watching
for the very first time
what do you tell them the key to getting
out of debt is
i would say
faith and submitting to the plan first
of all and you need to take the time
to sit down
and if you're married sit down together
write out all your debt on paper
and uh don't judge yourself too much but
take a good long look at it
come up with a plan
and then write a budget and stick to it
and i would also suggest listening to
the show as often as you can because
every show
you learn something new and it gives you
the motivation
and encouragement to keep going yeah you
know george i agree with that you ought
to listen to every show we do i'll make
every minute of every show we do is
important
i'm kidding but thank you thanks for the
promotion yeah it's awesomeness
well it really kept us going
well you got to have you got to have
stuff that's just feeding your brain
because there's so much crap out there
that your brain turns into crap if all
you do is if you watch the tv all the
time oh my god your brain will melt it's
just it's just awful yeah
i accidentally turned on the news
channel earlier today up in my office
they were trying to hook up a thing for
the computer and the tv comes on and my
brain almost melted before the lathering
it was awful wow
i'm like substantially dumber for that
three minutes of tv that was out there
but uh yeah way to go guys i'm so proud
of you how does it feel
oh free free yeah
and just nothing can take us down we
just
nothing can come in the way now nothing
can stop us as a family we are united
front and we get to change our tree
forever for our family tree forever for
our young kids more than this change
your finances it feels like a change
your spirit it does yeah yes wow that's
incredible and you did it for those
little kids that's her wife that was
your that was the starting point and
that's what your legacy is going to be
all about changing that family tree and
you guys have done this yeah you go from
worrying about whether you can feed them
or not to completely changing the family
too wow they look like they're eating
okay yeah that's good
that's incredible they're adorable they
are very well done good job you guys all
right let's bring them into the shot
what are their names and ages
we got hendrix is two going on 21.
jackson is five ah okay very fun
good stuff all right cool that's your
why right there that's a good reason for
doing it and worrying about whether you
can feed them or not led you to that
first budget that's the whole thing
that's good good stuff so tiffany i just
want to ask you because you were you
were there you were the scared mom
looking at the budget going we can't
even afford diapers in daycare talk to
that scared mom out there who's maybe
doing a budget for the first time who
feels just overwhelmed seeing all the
payments go out you just you have to
look at it you really have to look at it
as something bigger than you you have to
define your why
and your why has to be bigger than any
distraction
that can come in your way
you have to have that fight that grit in
you
to want your family to succeed to want
to be better and to want
the best
you can ever provide for your kids and
so for me my why was bigger than
anything car troubles credit cards
people telling us that we couldn't do it
anything that got in the way it was just
a distraction and we just never let that
come between us very cool well we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure without a doubt that's where
you're headed and uh also a copy of
total money makeover for you to give
away and to cause to be able to cause
someone else to be disrupted in that way
so good stuff you guys all right it's
andrew tiffany hendrickson jackson from
lafayette louisiana 82 000 paid off in
21 months making 90 to 150. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
those kids are bouncing off the
walls that's amazing it's the cookies we
fed him or debt freedom it's it's all of
the above brothers it's all it's all
similar to caffeine when you're that
size that's true the adrenaline rush
that's incredible good good stuff you
guys man you know
andrew said something really important
george
um
if the subject of money
instantly causes you
to be anxious to have anxiety to get
stressed out
um
i've heard people over the years say
well i just can't do math i'm just not
good at this um there's a tremendous
amount of shame
like everybody else seems to have their
act together but me
now people don't say that out loud but
that's that's stirred in a lot of people
but
you know there's a balance between
that and um
moving away from that kind of shame but
moving into
okay here's the facts
i've done i'm doing some things that are
destroying me i've got to stop doing
those things
and andrew said hey i don't remember
exactly how i phrased it because when
you do the budget you got to kind of
accept
the the what you've done
but not not be so ashamed by that you're
overwhelmed not be so condemned by it
that you don't move forward yeah i don't
know how exactly how you said it but
there's something you embrace the
reality of it without the shame instead
of being crushed by it yeah and you go
okay
i did three dumb things here i'm never
gonna do those dumb things again but
that doesn't mean i can't move forward i
can't be successful it just means that
that's a learning process for me yeah
and looking into that mirror is the
first step that everyone needs to take
to change that mirrors it's hard it's
hard brutal it's like watching our own
video back that's true we don't have to
worry about that though because you
listen to every minute of it that's
right everything we say is on the
internet forever not scary at all
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com
is the
number one
online retailer for custom window
coverings
that's pretty amazing
you get free samples free shipping
new promos all the time you can save
even more always use the magic word the
promo code ramsey
today's question comes from denia in
florida
she said i'll be getting married soon to
a man who is also previously divorced we
are 55 and 45. he has property that his
parents left him that he would like to
go to his children upon his death i
don't disagree but we are struggling
with a couple of issues is the best way
to handle this to have a prenup
agreement regarding the property also i
struggle with the fact that the place
that will be our home doesn't really
feel like my home i worry that i'll
spend the rest of my life improving the
property only to have zero ownership of
it when my husband passes i'm not sure
how we deal with both of these things
hmm
wow that's a great question
there's there's definitely a dilemma
here she wants ownership but he wants it
to go to his children instead of her
well she's the verbiage that she's using
is not greedy and grabbing no but she
makes a valid point she's only 45 years
old she lives there 30 or 40 years and
they fix up the house with money that's
also hers over the years and then it's
all gone that feels unfair and not only
that he dies and she's 55 years old has
to move
for what's been her home for 10 years at
that point or 15 years or whatever the
number is right and so she's got some
valid points obviously he does as well
um because this is family property and
he would like it to stay
in the family his parents left him that
property so that does put it in
his interesting light
hmm
well here's the thing
okay uh here's the here's what's by
here's what's the the argument in my
mind it's as if the past is arguing with
the future
it's a good way to put it
and
what are we going to place more value on
this marriage relationship
or making sure this house goes to these
kids
so i'm trying to think
what i would do if i were in his shoes
and i had some property
um and how do we honor her and take care
of her i'm not sure
uh a prenup is obviously an order
uh a will
in conjunction with prenup so that
everything is laid out but i don't know
how to make sure she's taken care of if
this property turns around and goes to
them in terms of a a place to live and
be
recouping and really you've got the
emotional loss if she lives in that home
20 years it's more hers
emotionally than it is those kids yeah
and i guess i question why he wants to
leave it to the kids other than this is
family property and i wanted to stay in
the family but is she not family that's
what she's feeling like you know she's
the step mother the you know it's a
cinderella syndrome right um in in that
sense she's not the evil stepmother but
i mean
um
i mean to the property it doesn't seem
like it's it's all that you know what i
think you've got to decide what you
value here
what do you value more he needs to
decide what does he value more
marriage and the future with this lady
if so i think they need to go buy
another house
that the two of them own together
and they can keep this house and rent it
and it can go to the kids
yeah i wouldn't live there i wouldn't
make my home there it feels weird to
choose the kids or the wife that just
feels like it's going to be
uncomfortable
and i i think if you want to leave the
if you want to keep the property in the
family uh but she can't make a home
there
because it's temporary yeah
um it's never going to be hers and it's
going to affect their relationship
yeah so you just can't place the
stuff above the relationship the
relationship you know we arrange the
stuff around the relationship not the
relationship around the stuff
that's what i'm doing yeah
what is it you wanna what is it your
value the kids are gonna be okay i mean
you can leave the money there's a lot of
ways to bless the kids but it feels like
this process it feels like this house is
somewhat up on an idol yeah
it symbolizes something yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna rent it out or i'm gonna sell
it
and i will leave it to them
in the will
and it can be in a prenup that's fine no
big deal and i'm but i'm not gonna live
in it i'm not gonna make my future wife
my future life
live there besides that she may not want
to live where his other wife was
that's true yeah you know that that's
also can be weird whether she passed
away or whether it was a divorce we
don't know
but um that can be also weird there's a
lot of ingredients that could create a
recipe for resentment here and that's
what i don't want yeah i'm not living in
that house
i don't i'm not living it i think that's
the answer that's just me and i'm trying
to figure it it's a very
sticky question yeah there's no clear
answer weird i don't know exactly what
to do with it it's not you're right it
doesn't it doesn't come to mind you go
oh that's the answer because a prenup
doesn't solve
her
no it only solves him
a will doesn't solve her it only solves
him
desires and problem
you could even put in the prenup or in
the will that any monies any repairs or
improvements done to the home
are reimbursed to her
upon his death out of the life insurance
or something else so you can make her
right financially but you can't make it
right that she lived there for 20 years
it becomes her home and then it's not
there's a true emotion she's not got
control of her own home yeah and that's
just not gonna that's not gonna work for
me yeah it's a valid question yeah good
stuff good stuff hey thanks for the
thanks for sending that in that that's a
that's a wake-up call right there
so uh is this a good idea prenups
oh yeah in general we say don't do them
that's right the exception is if you've
got a real high net worth and you've got
a lot of assets and things going on
that's where we go okay maybe we need to
look at this through a different lens
yeah because
not because of the spouse in all my
years of doing financial coaching the
potential spouse is not the problem it's
their crazy family yes
people think people come in who feel
entitled
uncle louie feels entitled because his
niece married a wealthy guy or his
nephew married a wealthy lady whatever
it is right and so there's just there's
weird crap out there in these families
man and so
and if you just go if you just put up a
wall and you go up there's a prenup and
there's you don't get anything so
uh and i recommend it just for clarity
and for that now i don't recommend a
prenup where there's very small assets i
mean it needs to be
an extreme difference like one person
has almost nothing one person has two
million dollars or more something like
that it's not you know like one lady
called and said or emailed and said uh
my boyfriend wants a prenup to uh
for his classic car
oh wow i'm like don't marry him
he looks like he likes his car more than
you yikes you know this guy's not
marriage material he's he's weird
so yeah you know i just want to tell my
daughter if they come in you know my son
if they said no the they want to prenup
for this little tiny stupid butt twenty
thousand fifty thousand dollar item
that's just silly yeah so it's gotta be
we're talking you know a few million
dollars in assets and
they make just an average salary we want
to make sure that those assets are
protected from crazy yeah yeah and this
right here is
has got a different element to it that
is trying to make sure that the
the family assets are passed through to
the kids is all that's all they were
doing there that's different than i've
got to protect my assets from you that
i'm this person marrying you you know
that kind of thing we don't really have
to protect them from you george you're
not i hope not you're not gonna i'm not
a danger to anyone you're not a danger
not even i mean a little girl could take
me in a fight so you're safe
you're safe out there guys don't worry
oh man
not true thank you thank you for the
vote of confidence i've seen you you're
vicious you're a vicious i'm scrappy
you're scrappy you're scrappy oh man
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five um yeah this idea
that when you can agree on your spending
you've agreed on your future goals fears
your value system and when you can agree
on things like
the balance sheet like who gets the
house
and you know you're coming into a a
relationship one of you has got an
imbalance uh there is an imbalance of
assets one of you got a bunch one of you
doesn't have
then those are the kinds of things that
it's really healthy to talk about
because when you do not get all those
cards on the table played face up in a
relationship that's when you get into
problems yeah and we see that all the
time but it's a different spirit that
we're talking about versus the
traditional prenup where you're going
hey this all goes south man i want to
make sure i'm covered you always think
of that george clooney movie you know oh
yeah
the uh the massey prenup has never been
broken you know it's just great it was a
great movie a little payback
and uh but anyway yeah it's that that's
the ultimate prenup movie right there's
clips from that we should use when we're
teaching this but we'll get the right
except we'd violate copyrights and that
that kind of stuff
oh
good job george good hour sometimes
people in the booth the booth people did
a great job today booth folk booth folk
that's all we call them this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the ramsey networks podcast the fine
print
is my co-host today we're answering your
questions about your life about your
money your career your mental health
your relationships it's all right here
and it's all called the ramsay show the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two
five natalie is going to start off this
hour in san antonio hi natalie how are
you
i'm good how are y'all better than we
deserve what's up
um well i'm looking for some help uh for
my mom actually
um i'm active duty military um and an
only child i'm stationed in san antonio
my mom she's 64 and disabled we're
originally from louisiana due to the
hurricane season that was just wild in
2020
i moved her in with me just because the
stress of running away from hurricanes
and her disability was a lot
so i moved her in with me in san antonio
and right now we're looking at selling
the house
my question is well two if you don't
mind
one are there any tax laws that maybe
we need to be aware of or into
with this being
basically all she has as far as
retirement what's the best thing to do
with this money um since it'll be
probably a hundred thousand maybe a
little bit over
okay what will the house sell for
um a little over a hundred dollars
it's pretty sure it's paid for okay
there's no taxes
first question's easy there's no taxes
single person can make up to 250 000
profit on their
uh on their primary dwelling
their residence
and uh they don't
pay any taxes at all on it and so that's
her situation she's gonna pay zero taxes
now
you're in the military sir are you what
happens when the military moves you
you're just gonna move her
uh well i bought a home in san antonio
so she'll be living here
if you move off
yes
who's going to take care of her
oh well
her limit her disability isn't to the
point where she's confined to a
wheelchair or needs assisted living at
that time she can still walk around like
it's more affecting her joints and bones
but she can still move around feed
herself get dressed things like that
okay so she's going to live in this
house regardless of where you live
yes how old are you
i'm 25. what happens when you get
married
i mean that's not on the table right now
but
um
i actually have not thought about that
okay i just got to have a plan for mom
and um
and i i
you know i i don't want a plan where uh
yeah where there's
where we're pushing things together we
don't have to so
it sounds like in the near term in the
next like five years you're not going to
need housing for her
other than what you've already got the
housing other than she can stay with you
probably for that long anyway right
but um right you know
she might need this money to
buy a um a retirement uh condo in a
retirement community or something should
you get married to start your family if
you don't have her in the house at that
point i'm not trying to kick her out i'm
just trying to make sure we've all got
options so that means we're just
investing the hundred thousand right she
doesn't need the money does she
nothing no she still has social security
and i mean that's that's really all she
needs
right now what's coming in from social
security what's her total income per
month
um right now it's about 1500 a month
okay she has no housing but she has no
housing cost
no no
but she might one day
right but i'm saying today the 1500 a
month you can live on if uh since
natalie's furnishing
food shelter utilities right yeah yeah
yeah which is not a good long term
louisiana
yeah the louisiana utilities are all off
she might pay for um maybe less than 50
for the home insurance yeah but i'm
saying if the house is sold and she's
living with you
you're covering utilities and housing
right right yeah and so the 1500 will go
a long way then she'll be okay without
having to mess with the hundred thousand
so let's let's sit down with a smart
investor pro and get that hundred
thousand invested
um
because it's probably gonna be five
years before she needs it
okay
so click smart fester pro at
ramseysolutions.com find the person that
we recommend sit down with them with
your mom and she needs to understand it
not do it because i said to her someone
else said to but i think a good
long-term investment's in order there
yeah and based on you know we've got an
equation about every seven years if you
got about a ten percent rate of return
that money would double
so after seven years sitting there i
mean if you did nothing to it that could
be two hundred thousand dollars right
which could get her a property in seven
years yep absolutely i like this plan
and so there's a lot of different
options here that we've got but yeah
just the the trick is not to burn
through that money that's the trick
that's why i was asking about the living
on the 1500 and making sure that we're
we're able to do all that so good
question thank you for joining us tom's
with us in kansas city hey tom welcome
to the ramsay show
thank you dave what's up
well i've been listening to you for i
don't know 20 30 years it seems like
forever i don't know life without you
really um
but i i've been following your your
principles loosely okay i'm not as rigid
and as rigid as probably i should have
been and i could be wealthy probably if
i did
but i want to know right now with my
wife and if we're anywhere near
we want to retire early we want to start
you know living and giving like no one
else when can we start that
do you have a paid for house
yeah 500 000 awesome you got no debt you
got the emergency fund
no debt 150 000 cash 2.3 million in
retirement you guys are incredible
totally
thank you thank you
how old are you guys oh i'm i'm 54 she's
60.
okay
man well you guys have done really well
i mean now's the time what are you
waiting for what's holding you guys back
really
um i don't know i just don't i don't you
know i don't know i don't you know as
far as
she gets health insurance for us because
it's federal
so that that insurance that that will be
good but um we're looking at maybe a
year or two and you know we can start
giving some money away um
to people i want to give it to people
who like secret santa claus santa claus
type thing you know
yeah an anonymous or you just go to
somebody who you know needs and could
use twenty dollars
well here's the thing um what you do is
you just say this is the income we live
on and it includes our giving budget and
this is the income we live on and it
includes our fund money and our our
splurge money and this is you know and
when you look at 2.3 million dollars um
if you said i'll just round numbers 10
be 230 thousand a year be your income
you don't wanna you don't budget that i
don't think you're not that guy but i
mean if you if you lived on a hundred
thousand bucks a year you could do a lot
of giving on that right
yeah if you're not talking about giving
away a million dollars then yeah you're
ready to go if you're talking about
giving away 20 bucks you you're late to
the party you should already been doing
that
so uh but but yeah i
i think you're in a position to enjoy
the money you've lived like no one else
you're you know you just need to sit
down and do some math and what sharon
and i do is we just
give every dollar a name
and then when we give that we don't
worry that we're not going to eat
because we gave away too much or we're
not eating so much that we didn't give
away anything
you have to balance it all out and just
have a little game plan that's all it
takes
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
well tax season is upon us
i know try to contain your excitement no
one likes doing their taxes especially
when you realize what the big software
companies are up to every year these
companies lure you in by saying you can
file your taxes for free then when
you're knee deep in the filing process
they sucker punch you with up charges
loan offers credit card pitches it's
just not a good experience there's a
better way to do it
it's called ramsey smart tax
this is our online tax filing software
with ramsey smart tax you get all the
deductions all the forms every tax break
you deserve and the best part is the
price hours is already much lower than
the leading competitor and you won't
find hidden fees
plus this year we have a promo code that
will truly make it free to file your
federal
income taxes
go to
ramseysolutions.com smarttax to get your
promo code and file without the
surprises
ramseysolutions.com
smarttax
chad is with us chad's in lansing
michigan hi chad welcome to the ramsay
show
how you doing better than i deserve
what's up
well me and my wife kind of kicked an
idea we have the last couple years
taking an idea of building a house we
bought this 52-acre farm back in a few
years ago and we paid that off and then
we there was a house that came up for
sale next to it we bought that's kind of
a small house
and we kind of rent it we rent it out
now
but our dream is to kind of build a
house
and i just you know 370 000 and just
makes you know makes you real nervous
we kind of live below our means and
we just don't know the right decision or
not
what's your income
uh we make about 130 000.
how much money you got
uh i got a hundred thousand of my
savings i got a thirty thousand dollar
emergency fund and i
000 in my business coming
wow about retirement
what was that how much in retirement
i don't have none that's another thing
i'm kind of worried about
how old are you
41. okay yeah time to get in gear
i know it is
yeah
so where are you guys living right now
well a friend of mine passed away about
10 years ago when his son was uh he was
in a wheelchair and needed a little help
so i lived in that guy's house and i
just make sure this guy has what he
needs so we don't have no expenses there
but he's 61 and
when he does if something happens to him
we got 30 days to get out so we kind of
i don't know it seems like we're 40 we
kind of want to get our own place and i
don't know
no
well if you put a hundred thousand down
on 370 000 on a paid for piece of ground
um you have a 270 000 mortgage
making a hundred and something thousand
dollars a year you ought to be okay
i think so yeah 15-year fixed rate or
less
yep so did i take
my 100 000 savings should i pay this
other house off rental house off oh you
owe money land for equity your money i
owe 50. dial 52 000
what's it worth what's it worth
that's what about 150 i was hoping maybe
sell it to one of my kids here in you
know four or five years
well i'll give you another 100 if you
just sold it and then you put 200 down
on your two on your 370 you'd only have
a 170 mortgage
yeah yeah what's the income on the
rental
uh i get 800 bucks a month it's
that's low but a couple guys i know that
worked for me so yeah i'd sell it
i put 200 down
i put 200 down on the 370 and i start
break ground on the 370 immediately
okay and that'll give you some peace
around these numbers if that's scary
i want to move you towards getting this
this new house paid off more than i want
you to be a landlord renting something
out for 800 bucks
yeah yeah yeah
it just sounds more fun to me i can
visualize five years from now you're
saying i can visualize you're 45 years
old 46 years old and you're living on in
this 370 000 house on 52 acres and it's
all paid off but you don't own the
rental
whoopty doopty
i like that plan a lot better and then
getting gear on this investing stuff
yeah get start putting 15 of your income
away immediately for retirement maybe
before another 20 25 years i mean you
could absolutely retire millionaire with
no problem so i like this plan
good point good point baby steps
millionaire's book is coming your way
hold on we'll have the team pick up and
give you a copy it's the number one
bestseller i just did called how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too
but i think you need to go ahead and do
that and start building now
30 days to get out is not a good plan
and if you get the house finished and
it's time to move in you'll have to make
other arrangements for your friend that
you've been carrying for there uh your
guys that are living in that rental are
gonna have to make other arrangements
because you're getting ready to sell it
and that's what we're doing dude and
it's not cold it's just where you know
you need to move your stuff towards your
goals first
and um
when you gather everything up and point
it at that one goal you're gonna get
there pretty quick
angel's with us in orlando hi angel
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you for having me how you guys are
doing better than we deserve bro what's
up
a little bit of background i'm an
immigrant i have five years in the
country
and
just right now my wife and i we're
starting to understand economy how the
money works here
so
um i just have my two trucks there's
about like eighty-five thousand dollars
in bed
and i thought that was perfect because
everybody have a loan on their car so i
started hearing the podcast and i
realized that i have to do something
about it but i wonder
if that would be a good idea i just paid
off these trucks or get rid of them
so i'm just looking for your advice
right now
i love it well you know that that is the
american way right you move here and you
get to get a car payment as part of it
so what's your income yeah exactly
what's your income my wife and i
my wife and i will make 170 and i have
extra
between 20 and 40k bonus by the end of
the year awesome
why don't you just pay these trucks off
that's what i thought but you know you
always say that you know
get rid of the trucks get a bidder
no sir my house and my truck you got any
money
uh my house
do you have any money yeah
yes i have around 10k on my bank account
not much where's your 170 going did you
just start making that are you blowing
it
no we just start breaking that this year
we get a new jobs work research and
managers so we get this um
right now what are the trucks worth
total
if you sold them today what would you
get
around
65 67. now they're under half your
annual income if i were you i'd roll up
my sleeves and get them sold or get them
paid off i'm sorry
i would just lean in and say all right
we're going to pay these off in a year
because you're not used to making 170
grand don't act like you make 170 grand
put it all on the trucks
yeah this is really new for us and we're
really excited about the money but i
don't feel like yeah don't don't blow it
put it on the trucks and keep the trucks
that or sell them i don't care if you
want to sell them that's okay and move
down in truck but you do need to be rid
of the debt in the next 12 to 18 months
one way or the other either by paying
them off by getting on a real tight
budget it's not that tight what were you
what'd you make two years ago
about 70. yeah go live on 70 and put 100
on the trucks
yeah that's that's the night i do i just
you know want to check it out with you
and give you advice yeah okay and based
on the numbers angel told me you've got
uh 65 000 in worth on these and you got
85 in debt so he's under water on these
trucks so it's not it you're going to be
in a predicament
even if you sell them you're still going
to owe 20 grand yeah they might actually
be worth more than you think they are
that's what i wanted to in this market
in this world
so um especially a truck either way i i
i think what you've got to do is you
just woke up and realized the american
dream parts of it might be a nightmare
and we don't want to live like this so
we're going to do this i just love
he comes here five years this year he's
making 170. it's incredible and just an
incredible way to go angel opportunity's
still out there for people who are
willing to work for it turns out little
man can't get ahead angel got ahead
angel got a head shut up
you can do this stuff people hang on
we're going to give you angel we're
going to give you a copy of total money
makeover show you how to do all this
whole money thing top to bottom it'll
walk you through exactly what to do
but in your case i would keep the trucks
and pay them off in 12 months 14 months
something like that lay yourself out of
budget lean into it make it a goal be
done keep the trucks and pay them off
what i would do
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage
eric and morgan are with us hey guys how
are you
doing great where do you guys live
lawrenceburg kentucky oh just up the
road cool yeah
welcome to nashville
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off paid off 94
408
good for you way to go and how long did
this take 25 months good
and your range of income during that
time i started around 80 and kicked it
up to about 110. good what do you guys
do for a living i'm a police officer
and also in the air national guard up in
kentucky and i'm an occupational
therapist oh very good good okay what
kind of debt was this 94 000
uh we paid off uh some student loans a
couple cars
a cell phone just a lot of normal
you guys sounds like you had a little
bit of everything
all right cool feeling well welcome to
not being normal welcome to weird yeah
glad to be here yes very nice
very good wow okay so what started this
journey how did you get connected up
with this ramsey stuff
well it was
fall of 2019 our oldest was a couple
months from turning 10
and i just kept thinking if the next 10
years go as fast as the first 10
he's going to be 20 and we'll have
probably two in college and there we
were
you know 10 years or so out of college
ourselves still paying on student loans
and
we really wanted to
change what what we were doing so that
when they're in college that we can you
know help them and get them started into
adulthood without debt amen that's cool
so um that's kind of weird yours is
following you up from behind and you're
staring down the barrel of theirs coming
at you yeah oh yeah that's a double
whammy if your kids are taking on debt
while you're still paying yours off it's
a bad situation absolutely we did not
want that so he was away with the
military and i never sleep very well so
i thought what better time to figure out
exactly how much debt we were in then
two o'clock in the morning when i
couldn't sleep
and after
i saw that number it just it made me
sick to my stomach and be able to sleep
at all and then i really couldn't sleep
exactly so
when he got home i you know kind of laid
it out and was like hey this is how much
debt we're in and
if i downloaded the total money makeover
on audible you know would you listen to
it on your commute and
he agreed and
that's kind of started wow and you would
just listen you said all right i'm
willing to sit down for six and a half
hours and listen through this thing i
might have been a little happy he was a
little hesitant at first
he said i'll do it on 1.25 speed that's
all you're getting yeah
yeah that's amazing it
took me a couple weeks maybe to get
behind it uh but once i figured once i
listen to it i figure if we're going to
do it we're going to go all in and uh
were you losing sleep you seemed like
you were kind of like i feel like
everything's fine did you feel any of
the weight she was feeling
uh
i feel like i think she was she has a
hard time sleeping when i'm gone but uh
i think once i listened to the uh
to the book
i was just
just ready to go and get it made sense
wow
that's cool cool very good job guys how
does it feel now that you don't have any
payments uh burden off our shoulders how
long you've been married about 14 years
going on for 14 years in the spring
never debt-free any of that time no not
until now not until now yeah yeah it's a
whole different way of looking at life
now it really is yeah wow very cool yeah
all right tell people what the key is
you pay off 94 000 in 25 months two
years you did it almost 100 grand that's
impressive yeah what's the key to
getting out of debt we never made a
budget and uh i mean yeah we until then
until then that was the key that was the
key oh god
the key is never make a budget no make
the budget
uh but yeah the problem was is we never
made it yeah so you know we made good
money and we were paycheck to paycheck
trying to figure out what bill was going
to be late and uh
you know it really just took us sitting
down making that budget and uh getting
everybody on the same page so that we
can make some progress yeah and for me
also you know the budget but also just
knowing your why and
having that reason that
you know kept you motivated and like you
know you all say you're doing it for the
so that and that's really what kept us
going was you know so that we can help
our kids through college so that we can
travel while they're little and make
memories and so that we can plan for
retirement so you know knowing that why
you know keeps you going when it gets
hard
it's a big deal it's a big deal you got
to have a reason more than i just want
to be free yeah
and uh because it gets too tough i mean
that's a hard two years
you all had to be real careful real
smart and sacrificing a lot of people
would you give up that was the hardest
thing to give up we like traveling and
doing things with the kids uh going on
trips and things like that so it
we were fortunate we uh you know spent
some time with family and they helped us
out and you know do little trips or you
know maybe take us out to dinner from
time to time
but you know tell them you know that we
can't do that right now we're going to
do it later yeah yeah that's
like i said we weren't you know it was
no we're not going to take any trips now
but once we're through this then you
know we'll
we'll have a good we'll make up for it
yeah exactly that's awesome that's
incredible you guys it definitely it's
amazing the theme today is i had to look
in the mirror and look at the reality of
my situation
and have the why that kicked that all
off and often times it's family it's the
kids and you go i don't want my kids to
experience what i have experienced what
i grew up in and now they get to live in
this brand new legacy that you guys are
building yeah that's incredible way to
go you guys thank you way to go very
proud of you what was the hardest part
for you that i'd say so yeah just
postponing uh all the extra fun
you know eating more dinners at home you
know coming home late at night after
work and just wanting to stop and pick
up a pizza but you know hey did anybody
know you were doing this do you have
outside outside cheerleaders oh yeah we
pretty much told anybody that would
listen
that we were going through this and
um but yeah our families were big
cheerleaders our kids um you know they
sacrificed a lot too i feel like you
know i one of my extra things that i did
was i taught online in the mornings and
at night and if he was at work or if he
was gone you know they would help out
with our now three-year-old the big kids
would help you know watch him keep him
entertained while i was teaching and
sometimes they missed out on sleepovers
because of it and so i mean they
sacrifice a lot
but
but now we can scale that back i think
they're going to be okay
all right
well well done we're very proud of you
guys you're incredible very good job
very good job we've got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you our latest
number one bestseller on how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth how
you can too that's your next chapter we
want you guys to go on and be baby steps
millionaires now oh yeah it's you're
right on track to do it you're doing all
the smart stuff
very well done and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away get
somebody's life started you got it
started with the tmmo audio obviously so
that's a total money makeover i'm using
inside initials here yeah
yeah that's it so all right bring the
kiddos in tell us their names and ages
yeah we have carson that's 12 macey is
10.
uh nolan is three and trevor is nine
months all right way to go guys looking
good very fun
good stuff all right erica or i'm sorry
eric and morgan carson macy nolan and
trevor from the lexington kentucky area
94 000 paid off in 25 months making 80
and 110 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream all right three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how you do it
we call it a scream because you gotta
scream scream good job you guys don't
you dare show up here and not give me a
full throated scream i like it i like it
i like it well done
man i'll tell you they're the the common
theme
among people who build wealth and is a
they get out of debt b they're working
together see they're on a budget but the
overarching theme is two big things they
have a why
they have a reason for doing this simon
sinek our friend wrote the book start
with why
and
there's
all of this creates just an
intentionality you know what what she
said or he said there early in the in
the time they were on the stage there
was we made a lot of money we never did
a budget
and um we had no idea where it went but
as soon as we started telling it what to
do it was magical
that's amazing how that happens when you
pay attention you go oh my gosh we make
too much to be this broke where is this
going let's find out number one problem
with americans money don't pay attention
they don't pay attention once you start
paying attention you start doing smart
stuff nobody does stupid on purpose
it's usually by accident that's right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day lamentations 3
25 the lord is good to those who wait
for him
to the soul who seeks him
winston churchill said success is not
final failure is not fatal it is the
courage to continue
that counts
one of my favorite churchill quotes is
success is going from
failure to failure without loss of
enthusiasm
man he was just a quote wizard yeah my
computer guys call that iteration but
you know
going from failure to failure without
loss of enthusiasm i like churchill's
better yeah that's definitely it
definitely it casey's with us in
billings montana hi casey how are you
hi dave um this is a dream calling you
to get your opinion on something so
thank you so much for taking my call our
honor how can we
long time listener i'm honored okay uh i
am 34 my husband is 43
and we own over 2 million of real estate
in a
kind of touristy area
in the mountains which as you can
imagine last few years has just blown up
one of which we own outright completely
and
we have that as an airbnb
and we're getting about 50 000 or more
on it
and
on our main house that we're living in
we own we owe i'm sorry 390
that 390 000
on it which the
passive airbnb money is completely going
to the mortgage we're like no this is
our it's our only debt we don't want to
have that mortgage and it's so daunting
if you just pay the minimum required
everyone so we have a plan that we're
gonna knock that down in like six years
well
now
my husband who is a contractor he has
worked to the bone since he was a child
he just grew up doing like harsh labor
he his body just can't take it anymore
doing construction and um though his
business does very well between you know
uh on a low year maybe 150 000 to a good
year maybe three hundred thousand a year
it's almost costing more to stay in
business because you can't find
employees
the equipment that you purchase is not
made how it was 10 20 years ago it falls
apart and you can't get parts to fix it
so we're kind of bleeding money
on the business side and now he's like
well wait a minute
okay stop stop
okay the premises is that contractors
are all losing money because of
employment because of employees and
equipment
bad premise i'm not buying
it's it's kind of um i mean he's making
money he made 150 000
we have two guys
and one of them
um
they all have their they all have their
specialties
why does he not delegate it
hire someone to do the work he doesn't
want to do anymore he's tired of it we
would love to but where we're at it's
very rural
and
i would say construction is probably um
the last industry
that um you know the youngans want to
work for it seems um we we've had a very
hard time finding people the most we've
ever had is three
and i think that's because your
husband's so dad gum picky and hard to
work
for well i mean
not necessarily because we
we don't really have any barriers to
entry um we have even
okay listen everybody's got labor
problems in every market in america
right now yes everybody does but the
whole premise that you can't hire
somebody
as an overall concept to do the work
ever
is a ridiculous premise
yeah okay
okay
if you want to quit quit but find a
better reason
well this is my reason actually that was
just kind of like a sideways segue well
you know hey
uh
it you know business you know it's not
what it used to be business and it's not
it's not more we're losing money but
it's
you know when you buy a nail gun for
instance and it lasts about 30 nails
and then you have to buy a new one not
only is it you're gonna have to quit
exaggerating
because you're killing me here
well nail guns don't last 30 nails and
then fall apart
really not exactly
we have had the worst luck with all
equipment it's unbelievable i mean it's
like you know and okay let's just
what's your question okay
okay so
we have the opportunity to rent out our
main house that we're living in now and
make
50 or if not more because it's twice the
size as the other one
um and we were thinking well at that
point we could sell our
business
and he could just retire
and do nothing
and
do nothing at 43 years old
well that that's why i was calling
because i don't it's not a financial
question that's just a dumb life plan
okay because you know you don't want to
do nothing for 45 years of your life
if he lives to 90. i was
yeah i think i i was thinking maybe
you'd say that but um
it's kind of like um
he's you know he's worked
day in day out to get to this point and
now he's just
ready for a change or even to take like
an extreme
and extreme pay cut and just do
something fun
um he's just he's trying to do something
fun and also make money doing it i think
that's a possibility
yeah casey are you working in the
business with him are you working
outside of that
i help with certain things but i have um
i have like a i have like a craft
business that i do
and i make do you live in buildings
yes
okay you're not in an extreme rural area
that's a reasonably sized that's a
reasonable size town i was there not
long ago we're
we're um a little bit outside of
billings yeah but i mean it's
if you're a little bit outside you have
access to the economy of billings to do
another career of some kind you're
obviously both done with the
construction business sell it
but for god's sakes go find something to
do with your life
airbnb is not the god's call on your
life and besides that that's gonna at
some point end
that's not this is not this is not got a
long shelf life i mean it might have a
five year shelf life it might have a ten
year shelf life but it's not a good
20-year plan to run an airbnb
uh because it's
it's an unproven process it's proven
right now it's doing real well a lot of
people doing really what really well
with it i'm not trashing it but um
you're making unrealistic money on this
real estate that i don't think you're
going to make throughout the rest of
your entire 45 years of life
so no we're not going to quit work and
throw up our feet and sit on the couch
and drink beer for 45 years
and live off airbnb money no i would not
do that and casey i'm feeling a lot of
this starry eyed about the rental
properties and what we could make if we
got another rental property and it
sounds like you guys are are pretty over
leveraged because you didn't pay off the
rental properties you've got your
primary mortgage now you're going to
have that mortgage and you're going to
move somewhere else and they're gonna go
what if we rented this out and we moved
somewhere else and it just feels like
you guys are just chasing your tail
trying to make this money you're
exaggerating on the one side with the
airbnb being better than it is and
you're you're killing me with your
exaggeration over here on how horrible
the construction business is over a nail
gun because the construction business is
actually the best it's been in 30 years
if you want to make money this is a
great thing so all this is is the
hyperbole around it so yeah cut the
drama back and and if you want to get
out of the construction business that's
fine if he's tired of it i don't have
any problem with that it's hard work i'm
not arguing that but find something else
to do before you sell the business and
then get the business sold
and move on to something else and you're
not in such a rural area that there are
no opportunities again that's overstated
uh billings montana is a sufficient city
to have a sufficient economic economics
to to create a career for yourself you
know doing something else whatever it is
you want to do
but airbnb is not your answer
hope that helps you bothered to ask
we'll bother to answer george good hour
thank you fun time it's this hour of the
ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you